taking you back to our developing story
on Janine that's in the occupied West
Bank where at least two Palestinians
have been killed after Israeli forces
raided a refugee camp there let's bring
in Ibrahim she's following developments
from uh near to Ramallah not engineering
itself just tell us about these ongoing
raids by the Israeli Army and and the
Palestinians who've been killed
the results of these raids are usually
deadly when it comes to Palestinians
we're here in a funeral procession for
one Palestinian who was killed on Friday
by Israeli forces fire is the fourth
Palestinian to be killed by Israeli
forces fire in less than 24 hour hours
this morning we woke up to the news of
the Israeli raid at the junior refugee
camp two Palestinians were announced
killed by Israeli forces fired in Janine
itself we know that Janine has been the
epicenter of tension we're talking about
more than
114 Palestinians who were killed by
Israel since the beginning of the year
in the West Bank alone and a third of
those have been killed in Janine we're
also seeing aerial enforcement when it
comes to the Israeli raids engine in
itself this is something we haven't seen
since the second Palestinian and the
father years in and years ago there's a
lot of tension it's the deadliest year
here in the occupied West Bank for more
than seven years and as you can see
tension is still Rising so what sort of
resistance do the Palestinians put up
when when these raids take place
[Music]
uh boy 17 year old Madi Ladue whose
funeral procession within right now has
jumped to the defense of his village
here when the Israeli settlers came to
attack people after that the Israeli
forces came back and uh of course as
usual is the case they were defending
the Israeli settlers leading to
confrontations between Youth and the
Israeli forces the youth here are only
armed with one thing which is rocks they
throw them at heavily armed soldiers who
are in location now in the case of
Janine it's a bit different there are
armed people are estimated by the dozens
they usually clash with the Israeli
forces they don't have a lot of access
to a lot of high and developed weapons
but they still try to defend the refugee
camp engineering now out we've seen also
militants and armed fighters in novelist
being mobilized being
exchanging fire with the Israeli forces
but generally speaking we're talking
about rocks we're talking about
Palestinians who are unarmed okay thank
you so much NADA Ibrahim is reporting
for us from Ramallah that's in the
occupied West Bank